all right 9:00 a.m let's roll uh repr
pledge
okay let's uh good to be back GNA knock
out our very last public hearing yay yay
um going to open up the public hearing
for House Bill 1150 recognized
representative wood for the purpose of
introduction of the bill representative
wood welcome back to election law thank
you thank you Mr chair welcome welcome
back as yourself and welcome fellow uh
board members uh I'm introducing um
hb150 uh makes two minor changes one
that's in the uh main piece here
removing political advertising printed
in newspapers periodical or Billboards
shall be marked at the beginning or the
end thereof political advertising
there's also an amendment coming down
that I believe we should have by the
time we do our session
to also uh make it clear that the sole
responsibility for this information is
the candidates campaign political
committees Pary causes and
other uh individuals or entities
purchasing advertising for compliance um
the only thing I want to add is maybe a
bit of the story mostly everybody knows
this case um there was a a person who
owned a $40,000 newspaper that was um
brought up on charges for failing to do
this over several years it was
interesting because at the time she
wasn't running and these were local
elections they weren't really big news
elections they were I believe uh
planning board and School Board um so uh
there was a lot of confusion on this and
it ended up that she got uh charged and
um a lot of people felt that uh this
just didn't make any sense for the the
uh all the problems that people think
are going on in the state these are the
things we uh find time to to charge
people for so um I I I believe um
probably people here know more of the
story than I do so I will uh open up to
any questions or thank
you uh further any questions from the
committee this might be the easiest one
represent Lane I'm sorry I I I guess how
she got charged the paper got charged or
the woman
or the woman who ran the ad a good
question thank you the woman got charged
from reading the uh reviewing it last
night I've heard bits and pieces of the
story but the woman got charged
yes and I think that was the big part of
the confusion was um she obviously was
confused I I don't know how many times
I've read through what I need to do for
signs and everything and I get confused
but uh it seems to be confusion on who
the responsibility was was a big part of
the
case um so we're on the same page print
advertisement in newspapers has a
additional burden in that if you're
running an ad specifically in a
newspaper you have to run a the paper
has to run a disclaimer on top of the ad
that says paid political
advertising um and that's on top of the
disclaimer that should already be in the
ad um so in this particular case it's
very interesting um the owner of the
paper was warned three times um to run
that part and just kept not doing it so
the question is is is that we work on
this obviously in exec and maybe even
actually in our work session since we're
already cracking this RSA open um is
that actually required if we're already
having a disclaimer if the disclaimer is
already required on the ad why does the
newspaper then need to run an additional
thing up top uh representative Howard
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I I apologize because
I walked in uh a minute late uh and I
heard that you had mention that there
was an amendment coming forward to maybe
handle this uh specific issue I I I'm
unaware uh but what was the purpose for
deleting Billboards from
this that's good question I believe in
this section of the of the statute uh
it's all about uh the rates so it didn't
seem to make sense to have any reference
to um adding political advertising or
some kind of uh mark on identificator on
the uh billboard or anything in this
category there's another section that
clearly covers what needs to be on U
print and uh and as I believe I believe
what the as a chair been said it seemed
like this is an additional burden that
is only for newspapers and it if you
read this section um it it really just
talks about rates and fixing rates with
the the the Secretary of State and on
the top of says by the way you know add
this as well identify it as well so it
didn't seem to make that much sense
there and just to be just to clarify the
there was two problems with this whether
that Mark needed to be there because
other identifiers were there and who was
responsible for it so the amendment I
believe will be out out by our session
will have something about making it
specific to the
candidate and the last thing in case you
didn't hear these were not uh Statewide
elections thank you and and the good
news is because we're doing our work
session later today which will address
this entire section of law we will be
able to effectively talk about it later
representative
Hamlet thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I always get hung
up on the the the grammar and I
sometimes I miss the point of the bill
but anyway in the section
after the the lined out section where it
says rates for advertising shall be
filed shouldn't we put with the
secretary of state right there rather
than down below because the rest of the
sentence no later than 30 days prior to
the deadline for filing for office for
an election well I think we file for
office with the town
clerk but so I'm just saying it I think
would be more clear I mean asking you
I'm asking you if it would be more clear
if we put shall be filed with the
Secretary of State should be up there
yeah thank you for the question I I
believe you're correct uh this type of
writing is uh pretty much uh in many of
our uh State statutes and when you try
to look through it and you try to file
logically you'll find that the per the
person
or the thing that has to be done is you
know about four lines into the sentence
so I wouldn't have a problem with doing
that basically it was just to show how
simple um this bill was going to change
we really W going to change it by much
so okay further questions seeing none
thank you representative wood uh only
pink card we have today is Katherine
langle um represent of Howard can you
grab that that blue sheet for me the oh
representative wood will do the Dirty
Work
cool good morning
everyone uh my name is Katherine LEL and
I am 20 years old from conquered I'm
representing open democracy and open
democracy does oppose this bill um on
the grounds just that um it
would uh the language that's kind of
being deleted would
the standards that it's kind of get
trying to getting at would
not I don't know sorry I'm waking up my
language skills are not there
yet um I in terms of the amendment that
was being talked about it sounds good to
me because it's trying to get at more
specific standards across media types
and that is what I talk about in my
written testimony which y'all have eyes
you can read um um I'm not going to kind
of get at
um at those themes today I do mention
the case that was mentioned by
representative wood and discussed about
by representative Lane and those
standards um that were set by that case
and the expectations that were set by
that case and uh considerations that we
should think about so on those grounds
um striking this language would be
detrimental uh to the Integrity of our
campaign processes and the already
fragile system of Med messaging that our
society relies so heavily on um but I do
like the the themes that were're trying
to get at in terms of standardizing um
expectations for media and political
persuasion
ideas thank you and uh I'm happy to take
questions other questions from the
committee representative uh
representative would you may not
participate you introduced the bill I'm
sorry
um but if I I I'm sure if if you leaned
over representative bone might ask your
question for you but I can't allow you
to do it I'm also happy to talk with
people after this I I am sure you would
it's nothing it's just one of those
weird procedural things I I I agree um
especially since you're on opposite
sides if you on the same side I might be
a little more Le but um I just have one
question um if no one else has any of
the questions which is that we already
require a disclaimer in the actual ad so
if I if I run the ad like why do we have
to list political advertisement on top
of it when the disclaimer has to be in
the ad anyways sure um in my mind it's a
matter of addressing things as you know
what they are and it to me it comes down
to media literacy skills um at least in
today's society uh forever in a year ago
it might have been completely different
but today it comes down to addressing
things as what they are like when you go
shopping it uh you have to acknowledge
things as uh
items or whatever um for this it's a
matter of like something that could be
used to persuade someone and to me that
standard kind of remains there um yeah
at least that's what I perceive it as
um yeah okay any further questions
represent L uh thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question did I
hear you mention other media in your
testimony in other words you would
expand this Beyond what's in the
existing
statute I mean
media be goes beyond print right and
print media is just one method of
messaging and it's I feel like those
standards could be expanded um I mean
we're in we're in campaign season now
and our radios and TVs and newspapers
are flooded with local state and also
National ads paid for by blank blank BL
blank um and standardizing like what we
expect of those
candidates local Municipal and
otherwise would be nice because when you
hear that message of paid forward by
blank blank blank you know it's official
so when you see on a newspaper
like some certain things you know that
it's
not misleading or misinformation because
that sort of those those terms are very
poignant in today's sort of society and
I feel like it could be comforting to
see standardized terms like
that okay uh further questions from the
committee oh we have seres Bay sorry you
are you are back lit for me so if I
don't see you that's like you are it's
like you're literally like glowing
because of the sun behind
you well thank you Mr chairman uh may I
ask a
twofer
okay um this question is actually for uh
specific to um the billboard I I guess
help me understand uh or if you when I
see a billboard I already assume it's an
ad are there Billboards that are not ads
or are we uh just distinguishing whether
it's an ad which every billboard is in
my hand versus a political ad I think
that distinguishing um would be good
because ads that are from a certain
candidate versus ads that are from like
an outside Source um I mean they're all
political ads so they would all need
that distinguishment um but I mean we
all see advertisements and messages from
like that are from different
um oh my goodness I'm so sorry
um how I want to say sources but that's
so not it um ads can come from all
different places so political ads are
from different Realms I guess I think
Realms would be the right word so the
candidate and their Associates or
whatever and then
also I'm coming up with like an example
so like a cause that that candidate
might support that may not be a
political ad or a politically based ad
so I guess I guess you're right no no no
forget everything that I just said
you're right every billboard is an
advertisement for the most part um it's
just that
distinguishment I guess I I forget
everything I just said I agree with you
on that
statement um so um are you saying that
uh the necessity of identifying whether
it's a political ad or just a general ad
has something to do with the lack of
media literacy in general I mean I think
so I think that understanding what types
of messages that we take in every day is
super important and I think that uh
acknowledging that
and
uh acknowledging it for everyone to kind
of see would be good and standard
that sorry I hope that I'm able to get
my message across it's
early I am also not a morning person so
I I very much uh sympathize with that
position of it's early um which is
ironic because I own a chare center
you'd think I'd be up at like 5: a.m.
but I am
not I'm there when it closes I don't
think I've ever opened it once um any
other questions from the committee all
right that thank you uh thank you so
much thank you last up is Brennan mcade
from the
infamous New Hampshire press Association
but really the union leader we all know
that
okay uh good morning uh my name is
Brendan mcade I live in Manchester uh
I'm currently the publisher of the New
Hampshire union leader uh as
representative Barry stated and I am the
President of the New Hampshire press
Association um I'm here to speak on uh
hb150 and is there an amendment pending
on this uh the SP the co-sponsor did
indicate that an amendment is coming
forward yes gotcha um so I do support
that Amendment because I think it
clarifies things a little bit better but
I will speak generally to this subject
um because I have learned in my past few
years as publisher way more than I ever
wanted to learn about campaign Finance
law and how it affects advertising uh CU
it's a bit of a nightmare um um I don't
know if you guys have
read RSA 664 it's terrible it's a
terrible terrible piece of legislation
because you guys wrote it in little
pieces over the past you know 45 years
I'm blaming all of you for this one um
but it's a terrible piece of legislation
it's very
confusing about what races it applies to
what it doesn't apply to everything else
and um I'm not sure if everyone knows
the story of uh Deb Paul Deb Paul is a
um woman who lives in londonairy she
publishes a newspaper a weekly newspaper
down in London
Derry um she also served on the Town
Council in londonairy um she has not
made many friends in doing that and as
part of her uh political activism um she
was for lack of a better word targeted
and they used RSA 664 to Target Deb Paul
the way they did it was by saying that
she was running ads that did not meet
the strict requirements under HB 664
including that they did not say
political advertising at the top even
though I sat through the whole trial no
one ever said that they were confused
that this was political advertising much
like your billboard question it was
obviously political advertising um but
because this law says that it has to be
labeled she was arrested she was charged
she was prosecuted by the AG's office
and she has um since been found guilty
and she has been fined uh which is an
outrageous position for a publisher in a
free state like New Hampshire to be in
um the uh attempt here um was to make it
so that that would not happen again the
amendment that is forthcoming is better
but even this one at at least removes
that political advertising requirement
at the top which people generally are
not confused when something's political
advertising um so that's what I'll say
on the matter I welcome any questions
other questions from the committee
representative prudom O'Brien hi thank
you am I correct in recalling that the
that the advertisements did say
something like political some of them
did some of them didn't they had a they
had a mix of of messaging on them um and
the reason why there's an amendment
forthcoming is because the uh way this
one is written uh would not actually
address everything in Deb Paul because
they tried to get her on everything so
it was that it didn't say political
advertising at the top it didn't say
paid for by in the right way so she may
have said like paid for by friends of so
and so but if you read HB 664 which by
the way is a a uh it's a law the title
of which is campaign Finance why is a
publisher am I looking at this law to
figure out what I'm supposed to be doing
on my job but that being said it says
that the at in that law it has to say
political advertising at the top or the
bottom and it has to have paid for by
with the name of the candidate or the
treasurer or the uh chairman of the
committee and a street address where
which no one does I mean I've gone
through and I've looked at our governor
the entire yeah no but Ian I'm saying no
one does
the our governor the entire executive
Council all of our federal delegation if
you look at their ads not their print
ads because we make them do it right but
their ads say on TV or on Facebook
they're all technically illegal um
because it's a very confusing law and
what we're talking about about in the
Deb Paul case was adds that if you read
the law it says that it only applies to
these races oh but then sometimes it
applies to these races so these were
like Schoolboard races and Town Races
that um you would have to really read
into it to understand that they apply
and so it was not only the political
advertising but also the the paid for
buing the way that it was um put in and
so it was a technical violation but no
one was confused Mr Mr qu you may be um
pleased to know that the reason I
dragged my committee here on the sacred
week of school vacation is we are going
to be doing a work session at 10:30
rewriting the entirety of RSA 664 to
make it more streamlined and transparent
and easier to understand how many months
did you give yourself uh we've actually
been working on it for now two years so
um 24 to be roughly precise and we are
approaching the conclusion of that works
so you may want if you're not busy you
may want to hang around um because I get
a feeling this will come up there yeah
it is it is uh it is messy and and like
I say the fact that this is a campaign
Finance law would make you think that it
applies to campaigns but in the case of
Deb Paul they applied it to the
publisher so back to the billboard
argument if you're going to have a
billboard right well are you going to
arrest the guy who painted the billboard
wrong because they didn't put it on
there and you start to apply it to
everything else um are we supposed to
know the requirements of every single
industry and everything that they're
supposed to do within that industry
right regarding advertising like the
drug industry is supposed to have all
these qualifications on their stuff we
get that stuff in we assume that it's
correct if it's coming from fizer or MC
or something like that but we don't you
know we're not in a position to police
the intricacies of that but according to
the AG's office and 664 they have put us
in that position when it comes to
campaigns oh yes representative Lane um
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr McQuade
um you may not parts of the statute
require a filing of rates in the
Secretary of State's office and and
parts of it say that you can't
discriminate among political parties or
whatever in in the rates that you charge
do you think that kind of law is
necessary is that something that went on
and so the statute was addressing it or
is that because I wasn't around when it
happened or and is it something that we
should maybe address and I know that's
not necessarily technically the topic of
this statute but I would like your input
if no it's not in there and and if I'm
recalling correct from the version of
the amendment that I've seen it's not in
there either it's specifically about the
advertising display not about filing
your rates um which we've done because
that was another thing that they tried
to ding Deb Paul on um we made sure that
they were there we're sure that we've
done it a million years ago but it
doesn't specify how often you're
supposed to do it is it every race is it
you know anything else so our rates
haven't changed they're still there
they're on file um and we make sure
which is tricky with advertising sales
reps to make sure that there's no
discounting there's nothing else so that
everyone's paying the same rate that's
very important it's um I know from
having been on the buying side of
advertising for TV that that is what
goes on in the state and yeah I would
suggest keeping that in there maybe um
not having it buried within the campaign
Finance law have it as its own section
um so that it's clear to people who
would be looking for things that apply
to them that it is um something that
them representative rtor thank you Mr Mr
chair thanks for taking my question um
in this day and age do you think we
should be adding social media rates to
the list of advertising rates that are
here I know that a lot of campaigns now
um M included have used social media so
it seems like that's an Omission yeah so
social media is is a very difficult
thing um and uh you know the publishing
of of newspaper and TV rates and radio
rates are pretty fine because it's the
easy things to quantify they're very
quantifiable right we can put in column
inches you can put in time for TV and
time for radio um the way that digital
advertising is sold and one of the
things that really keeps me up at night
is we display digital advertising on our
site right it comes through resellers
and it comes through Google we don't see
those ads it's not like we get a whole
you know output of the ads and it's like
hey okay make sure these are all good we
only see them when they're on the site
and we may not even see them just
because of the nature of the way social
media and digital advertising works you
get an ad that's different than I get
that it's different than representative
Barry gets because the social media and
the you know big Tech is looking at
everything you do and trying to identify
yeah we think you might like this ad so
we're going to serve that to you so
Those ads are sold on an entirely
different basis and the way that they
are sold you're never going to be able
to nail down pricing um which is not
great right it means that a big player
can probably get better rates because
they're buying volume than a small
player um I don't think you're G have at
it I say you know I'm I'm not here
defending Facebook or anyone else but um
I think it is important just the
challenges of the Way digital media
works are um
infinite represent B thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question I'm um curious uh how much the
fine was uh both in dollar amount and
how much is it relative to the net worth
of the
publication so uh the fine um that they
wanted was I think 500 per
charge um this is you you can look it up
we've we've run stories and others have
run stories that detail it um I think
she ended up paying just over $500 total
they pulled everything together maybe
$600 but um you know in in terms of the
the net worth of the publication I think
uh they stated she makes about $35,000 a
year so you can imagine that's a huge
chunk of her income that is going
towards not just that but you know she
have she had to get a lawyer she had to
pay legal fees she had to do all of that
um which the AG actually cited as it was
shocking cited that you know other
people got better deals because they
they had just pled guilty and you know
the judge actually had to say hey are
you giving her a hard time for
exercising her constitutional right to a
defense in this case oh no no no of
course not yeah but the judge also
called me out personally so I guess I'm
little biased what an honor um further
questions from the committee um I have a
question so this whole while we're in
the section of that
RSA I I don't think your dream of
getting it moved to another section of
RSA would happen um that being said we
know it's there now yeah everyone knows
it's there now uh would the you can
speak either on behalf of yourself your
publication or the nhpa but would you be
amable if we just struck this whole SE
and said you can't charge differential
rates from candidate to candidate or
party to party so like I say I I'm in
favor of that as a as a as a notion and
I think that the majority of um or a lot
of instate advertising is traditional
means and I I personally having been on
the campaign side I hate the idea that I
would you know go down to a radio
station and wouldn't know that they're
charging these guys different rates and
these guys different rates and I think I
think it's important that that exists
okay uh further questions from the
committee it's seeing none thank you
it's always good to have a proud w six
business in here I do represent w six so
and we appreciate it I I'm some days
more than others maybe um any other qu
any other people signed up to speak I
don't see can you do something about the
motorcycle I'll talk to you
later uh
um any other any other people wish to
speak seeing none we have no one on the
blue sheet um and online we had I just
had it up and I closed it I don't know
why I did that uh online we had two in
support 11 opposed zero neutral uh with
that I will close the public hearing on
House Bill
1150 um the committee is going to stand
in recess here until 1030 um but what's
going to happen is I'm going to meet up
with representative Lane representative
B we're going to go over the schedule
for next week get that done um I'm also
going to meet with the two two leaders
of the respective parties and go over
committee reports to make sure we have
everything uh if we do not have a
committee report guess what we're going
to do today um so um and then we'll be
back for uh 10:30 for the work session
on campaign Finance the U Cava bill um
so 1596 1133 and 1091 um and then the
uh um it's the AI Bill do you know
representative Lane do you know if
representative Brennan will be here
today she'll be here for the she said
for the perfect okay awesome we want to
make sure that okay uh with that we'll
be in recess till uh 10:30 we don't have
to go anywhere because there's only 10
of us so we don't have a majority so we
here
for
okay 11:30 back um going to open up the
work session on House Bill
11 uh uh 1596 1133 and
1091 um I tell you what since we're
missing representative Brennan let's
start
with uh we'll just tackle the big one
let's go to 1091 relative to financing
of political campaigns um since we're
fresh on our minds
anyways
okay so um we've done a lot of work on
this I want to thank uh the ranking
member representative Lane um
for all this I I think the goal here
with this bill which we know is going to
need an amendment we knew an amendment
we knew it was going to need an
amendment when we signed off on the LSR
because uh to the previous testimonies
Point like you need months to fix this
thing um
so I what we need to do is kind of come
to what are the agreed upon and I'd like
to just take what the subcommittee
adopted as let's call it agreed upon
common principles my goal for this bill
in 1091 is that we get a near 2020 20
zero vote out of committee as close as
we can I want it to be bipartisan I
don't want I don't want in here to have
controversial policy changes so uh an
example ex of that is I don't want to
delete the entire section and go to a
First Amendment freefor all uh I also
don't want to like Institute the L
closing the quote unquote LLC loophole
right those would be two major
controversial policy changes so I think
can we start with that we're not going
to make controversial policy changes
we're going to go through and streamline
is everybody kind of nodding yeah okay
all right with that easier yes it's
easier said than done um so things that
came out during the subcommittee meeting
um there's like 19 different definitions
of a political committee so do we want
to start on page six line 13 which I
think starts with that because I think
we discovered there was I think actually
like 13 different definitions of a
political action committee so
representative Elaine do you want to
kind of describe what goes on in this
section we're on page six line 13 starts
with registration of political
me you have to Define political
committee so and I'm looking somewhere
in here it we defined it and we try to
get it down to at least three or four
and what happened over time is that
there are some very common political
committees that are regulated by federal
law and we kind of brought them into the
state without defining them and the
Secretary of State asked us to get it
down to as simple a definition of
political committees as we could so
that's what we tried to do and that's
why I commented it was easier said than
done but I'm trying to find the
definition page two I'm sorry I Thought
page six is the registration yeah so and
just so folks understand like I I spent
two and a half hours with um the
Secretary of State's office going
through this bill and we didn't even get
all the way through it for the changes
and things that they put in just on the
technical stuff so you know I already
have a laundry list of things and I'll
bring it up as we get there but the idea
on a political
and was it people coming
together it's a Committee created by a
candidate running for
office a political advocacy organization
and there's some thought Among Us that
maybe we don't need that at all but
we're not sure yet so that one might
come out I put it in there frankly as a
placeholder so we would talk about it
because I think when we talk talked
about it this summer we weren't quite
sure and I'm sure representative qua
will help me remember I hope but and
then the political Committee of a
political party and then the committee
of a segregated fund established by an
organization with a separate legal so
and then not created by a candidate and
does not fall within and it's um so it's
a catch-all yeah it's a catchall so and
then and then we tried then there are
some other types of committees that come
up but the idea was to basically the
notion of a political committee is one
that's formed by the candidate or two or
more people or entities that's a
political committee they may have
different objects they may be doing uh
direct expenditures um as a candidate
committee or they may be doing
non-direct expenditures as like a pack
or something like that so the idea is to
try and have as simple a definition of
political committee as we could get and
then we would try and Define the other
types the other thing that came up was
what is a candidate committee versus a
candidate and I'm not sure that I
captured exactly that in here so because
we talked
about it's very
confusing um for what a candidate has to
do versus what a candidate committee has
to do and which ones applied to which
and we were trying to make it clear and
I'm not sure quite frankly that I
captured that so that yeah so we Define
candidate page one line 15 yeah and then
candidate
committee which I know it was the
disposition of the
subcommittee that basically candidate
and candidate committee would be
effectively
interchangeable right the terms were the
same effectively right is there any
dispute to that uh the difference being
that the candidate is not required to
have a separate treasurer for example
doesn't have to recruit other people
yeah so there's still uh an important
difference uh yep so could we do a the
candidate the cand candidate or C C
candidate or canate committee May
instead of
shall well we're talking about
definitions here yeah in in Roman
numeral 3 page two line starting line
four uh and it's just defining what a
candidate committee is it's not talking
about a candidate we can talk about
definition of candidate later I have
some thoughts on that which I will share
later okay
um I do have a question
about on line five political advocacy
organization to promote issues in ideas
that may influence voters voters choices
where is political advocacy organization
currently defined I don't remember so
that is page six um where's it defined
though it's that word may that kind of
speculative that gives me pause it's
very broad I'll give you that well we we
were also talking about is it even
necessary to have that section in there
given because the political
advocacy is really it's a it's a
political committee I mean if they so is
it necessary to even have that in there
that's why I put it in there but it is
defined in here and I in the in the
existing statute I'm not sure I think
the purpose of the Pao was to comply
with citizens
united am I am I drawing that out of
thin err no um
because
basically I'm I'm not trying to have the
philosophical conversation just like
saying what the court said so I don't
want to devolve um but the the the court
said in the citizens united cases that
these Corporation entities have a right
to speech speech cannot be limited um so
my recall the Pao was formed to
Encompass that um I don't want to see I
don't want to enter in the debates of
should we should we not we're going to
have different views on
on citizens united however we don't want
to do all of this work and then have it
tossed because it's not compliant with
existing Supreme Court ruling so um
which is why um we're having uh both the
AG and the Secretary of State look at it
okay so the AGS so they're looking at
Pao do we need
it yes and they're looking at the bill
overall to make sure that we met what
they they came and did a presentation
and did we capture everything thing that
they did we tried but I don't know I
mean it's OB we could have missed it
yeah same with Secretary of State and
the attorney in the Secretary of State's
office is also looking at it in the same
kind of view is it compliant with both
state and federal law yes so because the
the the Nuance difference here so
everybody everybody paying attention at
home is there's a difference between if
I say people you should go vote for
Connie Lane that's one thing because
I've used the magic word Vote or I've
used the magic word election there's
magic words versus if I say thank Connie
Lane for her strong stance on
Independent regist te right and if I say
that in an election
window it gets interpreted by people as
okay well he's Advocate he's advocating
for a candidate but he's not using the
magic words so the issue that you run
into here is you're trying to Define
find what
is political you're trying to find what
is political campaign speech versus what
is political advocacy speech and the
reality is the two are very blurred yes
repres the question I had a moment ago
about where we originally defined
political advocacy organization I just
answered it for myself looking
through uh the text of the bill and also
the existing election manual yeah it is
uh
defined in uh section 22 Roman numeral
22 on page five line
31 so I I think it is redundant to also
Define it under political committee
right and I and again the question is do
we even need it and I I don't know if we
need it because um oftentimes the
political advocacy
organization um as represent ative Barry
pointed out can come out and try and
influence just by saying you know we we
like honey Lane because blah blah blah
or we like you know whatever and that's
influencing but it's not saying defeat
or elect so there's some magic words
around it and and frankly I'm I'm
meeting
tomorrow uh with the Secretary of State
um to go over that exact issue like what
can we do what how to how to do that
because right now it says defeat or
elect and I I think they would just want
to stay with that but in some places in
the existing statute we say influence so
it's trying to get them to be consistent
okay so I guess that's a good question
is do we want to do defeat or elect or
do we want to do influence doesn't
because that that's a thing we can
figure out yes influence influence
somebody to they there's an acronym
support um oppose um promote or I can't
anyway there's four words um that mean
and they're a little bit broader than
defeat or elect so and it might even so
that those like you said they're magic
words y so to get did you find you did
find those representative qua you found
those definitions and I guess we need to
them yeah the the current
language uh I'd have to look it's hard
to look things up while you're trying to
speak but basically it's it's a lot
simpler than the language in the bill
where which
uh let's see uh where the bill
says tries to influence the election or
any measure through support opposition
promotion or attack and includes the
following types the current language is
more influence the success or defeat
which I think is a lot simpler and
really carries the same meaning and and
that uh opposition promotion uh or
attack is used a number of places in the
bill where previously successor defeat
was used
and
uh I think that would
be that I think we should stick with the
original language on that I think it's
very clear okay so stick with the stick
with the original Pao language and we're
talking page two line one political
committee
definition means any organization that
and here's a a phrase that gives me
reservations it says expects to receive
contributions to me that's uh kind of a
speculative subjective state of mind
that can't be determined
I mean if if we said that receives
contributions are actually engaged in
the activity I think that would
be that's something that can be
determined by someone outside the
activity
uh speaking specifically of Roman
numeral 3 starting on line
one uh if
we change that first line to that
receives contri R
utions and going down to line
five uh item two political advocacy
organization if we if we took out that
part two and made that change in line
one I would consider that Roman numeral
3 to
change did you guys understand that
because I got a little did that make
sense
so you would so I would make a change on
line
five line five do we where we you just
take political advocacy organiz
organization out of this list of
definitions okay and then as long as
it's and then decide whether we even
need it yeah that's that's a that can be
separated out as a different
issue
so
yeah what this is a this is a lot of
material in this bill and I and I we
talked about it when you filed it and I
think we we discussed this that the
understanding was that we had a short
deadline to file and there were changes
we knew we could all agree on yeah and
that we needed to file something so you
you did the whole thing and we knew
that's what you're doing at the time as
a as something we could amend right to
something we could all agree on that's
the process we're in today yeah all
right know I think so I don't think
anybody disputes that when when I when I
suggest removing things I'm not being
critical you understand okay good well
want to make that clear like the nicest
dudes on the
committee one of the nicest dudes one of
the nicest people on the I I reserve the
right to be critical I can simulate it
anyway um okay so does do we have kind
of a general understanding
on that
situation which I know
is there's like this is going to be like
I'm going to download what we're about
to do and like play it as a sleeping for
my child cuz like campaign like the
intricacies of campaign Finance reform
um all right so any other conversation
[Music]
on let's call the political
committees um well I guess when will
need to come back to the candidate or
candidates
committee yeah we should put at the
definition yeah I I would really like
those two to basically be the same thing
like can't I can run as Ross Berry I can
run as Barry for New Hampshire I can run
for whatever I want to as long as it's
we understand what yes representative
bank so earlier representative qua that
uh maybe my understanding is that one of
the difference is that if you're a
candidate that you don't necessarily
need a Fiscal Agent or a Treasurer but
if you're in a candidate committee there
has to be a Treasurer so if you uh make
them the same can um uh in a candidate
committee can the candidate be also the
treasure or Fiscal Agent then they'll
make DEC so so that is currently the law
which is why I'm I I I I think it's
distinction without a difference because
Barry for New Hampshire I am the
chairman I am the Fiscal Agent I am the
candidate I I am all three of those
things um that's perfectly permissible
um you know it's that that's why I like
I'd like to be the I'd like to have the
yes represent
quy yeah one one of the higher
level uh concerns I had or or aspects of
campaign Finance La I trade off in my
mind is one I don't want to do things
make changes that will uh create greater
barri to
participation and someone who's thinking
I want to run for an office or State
Rep uh anything we do to make that more
complicated but that person might
discourage him so I don't want to do
that the other thing that I think we
need you need to consider and and which
I consider the main justification for
campaign Finance laws is that we want
the public to have the opportunity to
learn if a
candidate uh might be subject to undo
influence we discussed this air bit in
the our subcommittee meetings and uh a
way to to gauge un possibility of undue
influence is well an example I think we'
all want to know I think we have good
reason to know if a particular candidate
say received a million in campaign
financing from some individual or
organization right so that we would all
wonder if that meant that person was uh
being unduly
influenced by the donor remember
discussing that no I I do yes yeah yeah
and to me that is the main justification
for campaign Finance system systems if
the public knows this then they can make
their own judgments so those are two
things I want to basically trade off not
increase barriers to participation but
make sure the public has a chance to be
aware of the possibility of a new
influence I'm just high level I'm I'm so
I'm trying to bring it back to candidate
and candidate Comm
committee the candidate and candidate
committee yeah uh they're they're
functionally the same yes they currently
are now but I want to keep open the
possibility of having just a candidate
because it means he can just file his
paper doesn't have to talk to anybody
coordinate uh I don't mean this too
seriously but it would it would mean
that maybe someone who's unusually
unpopular could still run I mean we're
not putting a barrier that he has to get
someone else's cooperation that could
never happen happen of course
but um anyway you I hope you see my
point no I I I I do
um I I guess my point is I want them to
be functionally equivalent right so you
can run as a candidate you can run as a
candidat committee I don't want
different filing requirements I don't
want different reporting dates correct I
we we agree we still agree on that okay
okay so I I think we're actually on the
same page we're just we are on that yep
we're just not connected in our speech
so so you don't
want okay I don't think we need to touch
it then because we can address it if in
the filings if we're talking Roman
numeral 3 I think that's I mean I can
accept that with the changes the two
changes we just discussed so we
can I consider that one Roman numeral
3 item Roman numeral
3A
items one through
five and uh just while we're on the
subject uh I thought Roman numeral
3B uh was still fine you know
organization includes two or more
natural
persons Ju Just so you know one of the
comments from the Secretary of State's
office was we could delete this because
they think it's already defined
somewhere else so if that's the case
just not to have duplicative delete
definition B to delete B okay so I
needed to look at that just to see that
it's not duplica lively uh defined sure
okay
but in and of itself I I think it's a
unobjectionable
statement and it is or it is not an
objectional statement is not okay Roman
numeral three B it's very an organiz an
organization has to have more than one
person right there were some ambiguities
in the law is currently right written I
think that would resolve
them and uh Mr chairman just a moment
yep absolutely go ahead uh before we
move on too far when it when you think
it's appropriate I would like to discuss
the candidate definition too I mean
that's I'm as you can tell I'm a dog
after a bone on this so why not let's
talk about the definition of a candidate
so we we're now on page one we're going
backwards on page one line
15 welcome to campaign Finance um
yes uh ran numeral
2 uh paragraph D starting on line
27 knowledge that any other person has
received contributions or made
expenditures and for the benefit of the
individual and has not notified that
person in writing that that would be
part of the definition of the
candidate I I really don't think that
belongs there because it it puts the
burden of proof on an individual to
prove that they're not a candidate or
that they were aware they weren't aware
that someone else did this I just I
think that goes too far I I agree
because that's an action of another
right um it also it could be very overly
broad
um where somebody you may not you know
it's like you have if you if if they do
this to a lay person if you will and
they don't tell them to stop then
they've become a candidate right I I I
don't I don't like the idea of the
actions of another dictating that you're
now a candidate for office I think to be
a candidate for office you have to
yourself take some positive some actual
action to be a candidate so the the
current definition of a candidate this
is an expansion of the definition of a
candidate um the current definition of a
candidate mean is quote candidate means
any person publicly declared as such and
for whom votes are sought in an
election
um I actually
like this one a little better because
because I have said before you are a
candidate long before filing right um
and sometime often long before you uh
yeah you say out loud that you're
running so I actually kind of like that
better to be honest because we we had
discussion about exp exploring right so
this would basically Encompass that you
want you want to app Pine on that repr I
mean that's exactly why I I expanded on
that definition and this was I took I
looked at definitions across a couple
different you know venues so to speak
New York
DC I don't know I can't remember but
there were like three or four and I kind
of conglomerated them so you know it we
didn't talk about D and I think the only
reason it's in there is so somebody
can't do an end runaround and have
somebody else collect money for them and
then they and you know that it's going
on and you know you're going to run but
you're going to get around it by having
say representative Howard you know
collect money from me if I God forbid
ever decided to run for another office
so yeah I I understand it that's why
it's there I'm just explaining why it's
there but if you don't think we need it
there then no I I I would like to get
that out of there cuz it's it the the
idea that a separate party is doing
something and it's triggering you into
candidacy just doesn't that doesn't sit
well but I do like I do like everything
else I do like the expanded definitions
I think it's a lot better than what's
currently under RSA
um okay so does that you I think so yeah
on that one sat on that I agree I think
it's a good one um so we'll explore if
we can remove ran numeral 3 section B
lines 13 through 16 represent Lane
you're going to figure out if we can get
rid of that um all right anything else
we want to pound on this um by the way
in case you're s this is what this
subcommittee did all last summer so God
bless them this is really dry
stuff all right um are we good with the
rest let's look at the definition of
communication because I know that there
the language in here about um
influencing it like you said
representative qu runs all the way
through it so you know just to save time
I'll do a search and try and get rid of
them where it makes sense that because
it's in here too under
communication it runs through
it I think so I think when we talked
about I'm I'm trying to remember last
but I think we talked about this one of
my concerns was uh
editorials right um do we need a do we
need
a exemption for that right so if the
union leader they were here today we can
talk about them if the union leader runs
an editorial saying hey go vote for
candidate X right um they're obviously
putting that in publication in which
they pay for they're obviously
influencing voters but it's not a pay
you know we have historically never cons
considered those sort of
things paid political advertisements
right we've considered them editorials
right and they so I just want to make
sure that when we look at this
definition um so the current
communication definition just way is uh
communication shall include but not be
limited to publication in any newspaper
or other periodical or on any internet
site broadcasting or radio television or
any other any o or over any public
addressed system trans Mission by
telephone or effect simile placement on
any Billboards outdoor facilities window
displays posters cards pamplets lethal
flyers or circulations or any direct
mailing so what they do there is they
Define it they Define
it they just Define what a what a
communication is and then in this this
new
definition it talks about imparting
exchanging or sending receiving
information to influence of support
opposition promotion or attack of a
so I
think it it was
broader yes before it was broader now
it's
Tighter
and I we wanted to put include um social
media and other forms because the
definition was a
little at least those my notes indicated
that so that said any internet site but
it was also we I think I expanded it to
social media and other digal
expansion does any might have any
objection to that
expansion yes
qu personally I thought the original
definition was adequate especially since
it's includes but not limited to but in
this definition in the
bill there are a couple of phrases that
just I don't think belong
there yeah they they involve yeah there
forms of communication but by any means
of speaking I mean if you're speaking to
your neighbor about something political
there the two of you you're engaging in
political communication well you are but
it's not something that could
conceivably really be
regulated so that's one example or over
any public address system I I tood I
think the
intent uh it was a good intention but I
and another another concern I have with
with uh this section of law is that it
not be usable in such a way that you
could construe someone engaging in
protective act activities yeah could be
like a alleged to have committed some
wrongful communication and and by any
means of speaking or writing by any
means I think well maybe that's the
phrase that really so I think what's
happening is is they're defining
communication after they Define
political advertising the two probably
should have been flipped just
structurally um because I'd love to put
them alphabetical if you want me to no
no no I I I didn't mean that as a Chris
I I think that's what we're getting
caught up on is yeah is we don't care
about communication we cared about paid
political communication right that's how
we track it in our reporting system is
by paid Communications we don't want to
be in the business of policing all
political speech in fact it' be grossly
inappropriate if we did um but we we can
be in the business of transparency on
paid political
Communications um so we have the
definition of political advertising
before this which is looks like it might
be the same no
no I mean there's definitely overlap and
I kept actually one of the things I
toyed with was do we need both and I
think we do because all we're really
doing is to require them to disclose
that they did it not that they can't say
it or do it they just have to disclose
that they did it and how much they paid
for it but but the emphasis in the
reporting system is disclosure of
expenditures right so I just I just
think in this context the definition of
communication is just way too all
inclusive what if we put the two
together and made it paid political
communication so if there's an
expenditure right there's an expenditure
by a pack or
candidate then we're encompassing
everything and that act then that makes
me feel better about the editorials
because those aren't technically they're
not paid they're not paid for by a third
party for for example where someone some
individual was being paid to uh by some
some uh candidate or political committee
to speak to an issue someone's being
paid to go around the street and and
promote their message which would which
would then have to be in a disclosure
that would be a paid political
communication yeah because they're being
well there's an expenditure there right
they're being paid right right yeah
right I don't think we ever actually
have a disclaimer on speech I don't
think that exists in existing law yes
represent PR I'm sorry thank you uh if
there's a a concern about internet site
no including social media we need to
think about some new ways that people
are communicating like the the trucks
that drive around they think they're
exempt they're not on here trucks that
drive around with a
message so that would if you're going to
have if you're going to try to Encompass
everything that's a possibility that
needs to be included now well I I think
if you do if you put the two together if
you put two the two together then you
can
include you know expenditure basically
something effect of if there's an
expenditure here's a list of things that
qualify but there might be others but if
there's the expenditure that's what
triggers it the expenditure is what
triggers it yes representative power yes
uh so I believe uh vehicles are covered
in Roman R six right above uh the
definition of communication under the
definition of political advertising
attach to motor it says printed so what
they're saying is that's not printed
they're saying that that's digital
they're playing games do go we're not
I'm
sorry yeah I just want to follow up on
that one too people can make their own
bumper stickers and they're doing a lot
of that now so that's not paid people
make their own bumper sticker and should
they have to no because it's not it's
well it's an expenditure under $1
thousand do well there they want there's
also a specific exclusion elsewhere I
believe in the existing law but ALS
definitely in this bill that uh exempts
individuals acting on their own to
produce political and disseminate
political advertising so you could buy a
truck you know get a sign made for it I
believe you don't have to hand letter it
I don't think and you could drive around
with that truck that you rented or own
and on your own that's already
explicitly Exempted later just to point
that out but I don't think we can cover
everything here no we we
can't one of my personal rules is there
is no Perfection you can't cover not
even at a not even at any cost you can't
be perfect I think RSA 664 in general is
an attempt to sh Perfection
but Perfection isn't even really a real
concept but anyway uh so I would be
content if we just kept communication as
the original definition I think it's
inclusive
enough that's my opinion I
think I'm guess I would disagree I think
it needs to include social media
and some of the other things to expand
and no I I I think adding the expansions
in there I mean that's that's fine the
object I think the objectional part not
to speak for a% equality I person don't
have a problem with it is
the the the definition in current
statute is very it doesn't deal with
politics at all it's like hey this is a
communication right like these things
are
Communications and then what's getting
added here that I think is not to speak
for represent quity but I think it's
giving him heartburn is the part about
defining it as imparting exchanging the
information that influence the support
um so the communic so basically it's
communication so so what if we kept
because I I think the expansion like it
just seems kind of silly to let all that
hard work go because there was stuff
that needed to be
added but could we take the right take
the those two lines basically out 32
yeah take them part of 33 and most of 31
yeah after means take that out take that
out by any means of speaking writing or
other me we could put in our our mobile
Billboards um while we're there I'm
sorry what put in the the mobile
billboard trucks while we're
there I don't know to object to all the
things on that list but uh and this is
another place by the way where uh along
with uh
section Roman numeral 6 where I think
you could replace the list of you know
support opposition promotion Etc to
success or
defeat right I'm gonna have to go
through basically I think you could do
that everywhere and it would be simpler
too and we we want this we want people
actually to read it maybe yeah I want to
I want to get I want to talk to the
Secretary of State about that just to
make sure that we we talked about that
and I'm doing that tomorrow so okay I
may have to sounds like we'll have a
work session next week
um I knew we were gonna yes represent a
bum yeah I I mean I think it should back
to what you said before about paid
communication because just speaking I
mean people running for office or
speaking at all kind of different
organizations not paying for them or
being paid to do it yeah I mean so just
speaking is
like it's it's yeah you are owed to say
whatever you want um so I I
think so are you suggesting that in
section Roman numeral 6 on page 28 that
we say political advertising means any
paid communication put the word paid in
there yeah because because that's we're
comeing to you just a second represent
Howard but that's the in my mind that's
the trigger it's when there's an
exchange of money that that's when the
public interest of who is doing that
money exchange comes into play if I want
to stand on the corner here and Conquer
and say stupid things um I have a 100%
right to do that I don't need to
disclose that I can go make my own sign
I can say all the stupid things I want
to say and Lord knows I do um but it's
when there's a monetary exchange that is
pushing the promotion of that that I
think then the Public's interest of
transparency comes into play um so um
we're going to go to representative
Howard first we're come back to a bay U
but that that I think is that that's the
committee's intention right like that's
how I would understand it is we're not
going to try to regulate truly free Free
Speech but when there is an exchange of
money then there's a compelling interest
for the transparency of the exchange of
money okay representative Howard yeah so
I mean I I would have to agree with you
on that but we do have a situation in
the state where there is paid
uh canvasing in a lot of ways where we
have people who uh may work for the one
of the parties and they'll be paid to go
around and speak to people and I think
that's kind of uh important as to why we
need to keep that uh specific term in in
the legislation I mean I think that it
needs to be specified that yes you're
paying for them to speak on your behalf
but that's kind of uh what we're trying
to specify there so thank yeah and that
would be that would come out in the
expenditures report right that they pay
you know we paid so and so to go do this
um I don't want to get into the business
of adding disclaimers on paid political
actual speech you know um hey you know I
want to go advocate for cidex by the way
cidex pays me um it just seems kind of
clunky um and how are you going to
there's the receips in the expenditures
so when we get to the exchange of money
after that we have two points of
transparency currently we have the
expenditures and receipts form and we
have for certain media mediums we have a
disclaimer disclosure um so you know my
general disposition is if a disclosure
can be easily added it should be added
um you cannot easily add a disclosure to
somebody door knocking right they're
usually by the way handing out a
pamphlet that says who paid for not just
they don't always do that but they
usually do that um but generally
somebody speaking I don't think we
should be forcing them to to do a
disclaimer on that but if it's printed
if it's digital if it's over the phone
you know if it's some other medium
that's not that person in that moment I
think then we do need the disclosure so
that's the second part of that when
there's that money exchange is that
disclosure part of it um and
representative Bay you're up next yes
this may be too much in the weed as far
as uh the the paid um speaking so this
that because he said uh
the exchange of of money that you report
um in reporting so um would that cover
all like the fee if there's a fee but
sometimes you don't have a fee sometimes
you just cover their expenses so if if
the covering of the expenses something
that oh here you go this is for your
expenses so there's that but we also
report um uh contributions in kind so if
I invite someone from out of state to
speak on some event for my campaign and
I let them stay in my home or something
there's an expense to that so and then
you report it as um as an ink kind
contribution but monetary value so does
the paid cover all of that anything that
gets reported so that would be my
understanding is yes CU in kind contrib
in kind contributions are treated the
same as monetary contributions uh the
thing I always advise candidates are the
difference between an inine contribution
and a monetary contribution is the inine
contribution appears on both sides of
the Ledger it's immediate money in it's
immediate money out um instead of money
it's you know it's itemized value in
itemized value out immediately um
because you never actually took
possession of funds um but in terms of
in kind contribution that's how it's
always been treated so if in the
situation that you bring somebody up to
go campaign for you you pay for their
flight right you would the the person
receiving the flight would in theory
have to say they received a flight for
their whatever State stuff but the the
pack or the C paying for it would then
have to disclose I paid for this flight
um or if I take them out of dinner yeah
take him out yeah trust me we've seen
we've we've had bills about the
discussion of appropriate use of
political funds before um so I believe a
uh what was it a a was it a corn bake or
something it's getting on the way back
machine
there all right so are we uh anything
else on while we're while we're banging
this I'm going to give this this like
another 20 minutes and I'm going to put
the plug in and move on to the next bill
because I know this is how it's going to
go representative Raptor um yeah just
one question um I'm sort of naive about
this I'll admit that uh but under on
page two line
30 um it
lists um under political advertising
definition um what is being promoted or
attacked party measure candidate or
person the definition of person includes
business
organizations uh it's a fairly broad
definition so if someone puts out a
attack ad against Walmart seems like
that could be considered political
definition yeah that's a tough one right
because
um so so the reason that's a tough one
is if you have a person who's not
running for office yet but you know
they're going to right and you want to
start up on them
um right you know you need to be
disclosed thing that
a person is defined on page six so let's
take a quick Jer over there I think it's
person person is an individual
collection of IND Business regation Club
or any other entity created under the
law
interest an individual yeah in I I see
the point you're making right which is
you know if I if I talk bad about my
ex-girlfriend did I just engage in
political advertising right
um I don't weally in my
case
um we we we can't get to yeah we're not
going to get to perfect on this a
complete def we just can't Define
everything completely yeah that's that's
my feeling on it and we wouldn't want to
because we don't want we don't want
human behavior to be that tightly
controlled we don't want that I don't
believe I don't at least you if you try
to regulate every last Nuance of how
people interrelate with each other so do
influence that's where um what if we
added to of public political interest
just to kind of add some narrow just
narrow it down a little bit where are we
working on uh we're back on page
two person of public political interest
because then that would then you can go
and trash or X all you want um
whereabouts on page two uh line 30 line
30 run against but yeah I think to to qu
to represent qu's point I don't think
he's entirely wrong like we can get way
into the Weeds on that of me of uh but
you should be able to say all the bad
things about your ex that you want right
election of any candidate or any measure
is that what we're talking on line two
person because I mean the other thing
about that is like if you're going after
like a commissioner right they don't run
for office but you say the commissioner
is doing a bad maybe that's a better job
than
then
uh Welly I would think that's absolutely
protected under the rights guaranteed by
the First Amendment yeah I would say so
absolutely you're criticizing government
I think line two we just it's just leave
it leave it okay I'm fine with that I I
think it's understood there what that
means in fact I think we should go back
I've already said this we should go back
to that original language about
influencing the success or
defeat of any candidate or measured I
think that's where that one of the
places that
was right I think we should I I still I
don't want to get too boring with saying
this over and over again but I still
think that was covers it successor
defeat
but that's I think what people
particularly with attack ads they'll
come in and say you know attack you but
not really use magic words that say
defeat or
support so but they are clear
going for your defeat but the problem is
there's language I mean that whole
implicit stuff that we had to take we
took out the implicit because of the
court case so now it's explicit so it
does it have to expressly say
support or defeat or does it just in
some way talk
about supporting or or or deting you
know what I'm saying so that's why they
expanded it out and again um you know Mr
Fitch was not he he's still thinking
about that language too yeah so we may
have to take it all out anyway because
he thinks it may violate some case
law I I think the language that promotes
the success or defeat of a candidate or
candidates or measure you have a basis
there for making a complain if you can
make it
stick to me uh if you're putting out
material about a candidate that's an
attack is simply printing a candidate's
previous voting record is that an attack
well it is if if you disagree with it
it's also
advertising for people who agree with it
so I I just think promoting the
successor defeat of candidate candidates
or measure really think that covers it
okay it gives you room to make a
complaint if you
really yeah I hear you okay yeah that's
simple okay um let's go to page three
this will be the last page we'd handle
then we move on other stuff because of
course uh one other comment because we
spent a lot of time on at the committee
was whether there's places in the
statute that use the term including and
then there's places that use including
but not limited to so we talked about
whether
um they prefer including but not limited
to because um it's definite that's what
you're about and I and my question was
well what about something that in five
years you know and they said well if
that happens you amend the statute and I
said that's what we're trying to avoid
is amending it every you know two or
three years but but they are leaning
towards wanting to put in including but
not limited to and that's something I
think we should all talk about um yeah
and I I don't feel strongly either way I
just want consistency throughout the
statute that's all I really care
about Mr chairman yeah I I think that is
a way of really putting in a reasonable
person kind of standard yeah and well
I'm I'm not a fan of that cuz there's
lots of variations and what people think
is reasonable
but uh like I said there's no Perfection
here including but not limited to if
that's what you mean
then you if it's appropriate in
particular use I guess you'd have to
look at that there might be cases where
you have a specific
list
so anybody else have any thoughts
on yeah anybody else have any thoughts
on that one that this is this is what we
did for the summer it was
fun it was fun I I actually enjoyed it
for what it worth but this is like you
got there's like probably a 100 people
in the state that really are like whoa
give me fightings yeah
um okay we're GNA move on to page three
and then we're going to call it on this
bill because we could literally spend
could could I address one more item
after that of course uh the next area I
would have of any concern is on page six
so when we get when you're ready we
we'll get to page six next week maybe
next week um yeah no no but but I I mean
like literally we'll get to page six
probably next week we're not going to be
able to finish this today there's no way
obviously
yeah um all right
contribution every I want to review the
definition of contribution and see if
there's we're all good with that I don't
know does it look like it's
changed it has changed yes so um This
was um include is used here
um so it what one issue where we would
have to talk about including but not
limited to or you know it's yeah it's on
page yeah page three and then also
um the use of personal
resources um that's something we talked
about but we didn't it came up in my
notes but we didn't really I don't think
we ever came to any real conclusions
that I could find in my notes so at some
point we'll need to talk about because
I'd like to do it in one
place when people use their personal
resources how does that get disclosed is
there a um a minimum that will let them
spend without reporting it that kind of
thing so um so but because in here it
says or the use of personal Resources by
a
candidate on the camp you receive no pay
or the use of I you're talking
about
um I actually don't know if that's
appropriate to be in there what what she
talking about um she's talking about
three because this is shall not include
the services of volunteers who receive
nor pay or the use of personal Resources
by the candidate on the candidates
campaign that's in the existing law
actually yeah I know um and in if I may
speak yeah uh referring to back to a a
comment by representative rafter I think
I understood that or maybe it was
representative Bay I don't remember but
might have been representative Bay
talked about someone you know putting up
a
candidate uh how would you calculate the
monetary value of that I mean what what
what cost would you put on letting a
candidate stay in your I don't know
mean I'm not talking about anybody in
particular house certainly not mine
but but
uh I don't I guess at some point you
have to draw a line about you know maybe
stick to things that are easily
calculable like an airplane ticket that
can be calculated I don't
know yeah I know this is the current
definition my only my my concern with it
is is that that doesn't incl like we
can't have that include
obviously a self-funding right so it's
like oh I use my own personal money so
this is no longer a contribution because
we know you're allowed to self fund your
own race to Infinity um that's just
you're allowed to do it I think that's
what they're trying to get at um but it
needs to be
disclosed right and that's not clear
that's not clear and I want that to be
clear I think you need to disclose that
I really do if you are self-funding your
race that's totally your business but
you need to say you're self-funding your
race but
would uh would is uh cover also then how
do you do it like uh for example when
we're campaigning we drive from place to
place we don't log in all of our miles
and and the gas that we use or the wear
and Paar of your car and all of that
what
if what if we added like not the use of
personal
resourced by caner candidates committee
not not for the use of play political
advertising which is what I want to get
back to it's like so long as like if
they're using their car that's fine if
they're having they're putting people up
in their house that's fine whatever um
it's when they take a million dollars
out of their bank account and give it to
wur to run ads that and that I I run I
have an objection
to except I don't think we could worry I
wouldn't worry about someone using their
own resources yeah in terms of undo
influence I mean that's true they
obviously influence their own opinions
that's a valid point so I think we're
concerned
about
influence excessive influence from
somebody
else so I think I don't see a need to
get that particular that is the current
definition so um all right any I'm we're
going to end on communication because
that's about all I can handle and I know
if my brain started to hurt others have
to be um any other as yeah about as
clear as mud yeah yeah it's perfect it's
exactly what you'd expect from RSA 664
she give it then she take it away all
right uh we're going to come back to
this next week don't worry there'll be a
notice work session on 1091
so I'm sure they're all worried uh so
we'll move on now that representative
Brennan's here uh we'll move on to um
11:33 which is the AI um
I'm sorry 1596 excuse
me
um so reviewing this bill um I would
like I have some change I could send
them over representative brend um I'd
like thinking about it more and more I'd
like to REM remove images as being
covered by this um Photoshop is already
a thing and I don't think it meets the
intent of what we're trying to do
because it's not
fraudulent um audio and
video easier to manipulate people I
think people are used to the idea
of pictures and Photoshop existing and
being skeptical of that um however when
it hits the audio visual when it hits
the when that when that component of
audio is added and moving picture it it
it just re raises another a level and I
don't want I don't want because the
definition is so expansive because it
says or other digital technology I don't
want things that are photoshopped to all
of a sudden be met with this higher
requirement than exists now I still
don't think it's
necessary you want to respond I'm sure
you disagree and want to
respond um I believe that image is
important to be there because you can
still deceive the voter and if this is
about
deception which it is as is explained in
multiple areas of this bill I think it's
important to keep image in there because
you could still be showing an image of
someone doing something that they never
did in real life whether that is a
moving image a static image an image
that has audio attached to it if you
show a photo of someone doing something
they did not actually do in real life
the intent is to deceive the voter and
that's the problem and so I think that
we would need to keep image in there if
um limit
disinformation going out to the voter
that may or may not be fraudulent you
know appeal to that um
fraudulent definition
but would be um
harmful to both the candidate and the
public who would be receiving this
disinformation purposefully
deceptive are comments questions
concerns on
that good I have lots of comments on
this bill yeah
but uh if this is the right place to
share them right
time um my general thoughts about this
bill is that the
criteria that are being listed uh terms
like you know whether some image is
realistic or a person should have known
it was it was generated by some uh
something we're calling AI well that's
not well defined in my opinion but uh or
someone made a good faith effort to make
sure it wasn't
AI ordinary people like in terms of
Technology those of us who don't have a
deep understanding of some this specific
area how would we know that something is
AI I mean a point of this this I'm
using AI let it be understood I'm not
sure that really means anything at this
point but I'm going to use the term how
do we even the point of this this AI
processing is to make something
realistic and difficult to distinguish
from uh something that was
recorded uh that really occurred it's
difficult
I mean what person typically is going to
be able to know looking at it and with
disclaimers placed on
audio or visual recordings or image
recordings well if someone can put it in
there AI could be used to take it out
too so I don't see how this can be
enforced and it's it's coupling with a
person and on page
two line 8 and where it says uh I can't
candidate uh whose appearance action or
speech is depicted through the use of a
deceptive and fraudulent deep
fake uh in violation of paragraph May
seek
injunctive it's explicitly encouraging
candidates to take somebody to court who
shared an image that they may have no
reason to believe was fraudulent and
could not themselves conclude this they
because it's really looks
realistic uh and then also can bring in
action for General special or special
damages against the
sponsor okay but you know earlier on
it's on
uh page one line 15 it talks about a
person I have this image it may be
fanciful but I have the image that I
don't know somebody receives a video
through email and says wow that's pretty
neat it certainly looks realistic to me
con considering what my opinion of that
candidate is
uh and then just distributes it because
it's is also the word distribute used in
this in this
bill uh I I guess if someone if you
could somehow identify who produced
something that was fraudulent you know
deliberately faked and focus in on that
person I I could see where a candidate
might have a cause for action but not
for someone who merely distribute
something they received and there's
another term in here you let's see where
it makes a good faith
effort there were just a lot of terms in
here that to me are subjective and very
difficult to prove what a person did or
didn't know when they distributed
something and that concerns me concerns
me as a potential sub as aspects of this
bill that have the potential to chill
people's exercise of their free speech
rights so it's kind I don't know how you
fix that in this bill but it's a general
concern so I actually had a meeting
yesterday about The Spill and they
raised the lawsuit part to me um and
that was actually I have a list of few
things um so I I think in order to keep
going along with this we need we need
some sort of anti-s slap provision slap
is um yeah strategic you know it's the
it's the frivolous lawsuits um so we
need some sort of anti-s slap provision
I said well couldn't you do you know
have it run through the complaint
procedure process that current ly exists
for the New Hampshire doj um that kind
of met with some Fe push back because
then it's like all right I file a
complaint and I go tweet about it um but
you can do that now for anything so we
do need to I think come to some sort of
conclusion because the the the slap part
of it is actually very concerning of you
can't eat somebody we just heard earlier
today about you can eat up in court
costs um and if the candidate happens to
be an attorney they can file those all
day every day and it costs them nothing
um and the other person is gets gets
eaten up so I we need to figure out we
need to figure that out um what the a is
going directly to court the appropriate
solution or should there be some
other I don't know arbitration mediation
whatever other process that doesn't
involve a lawyer um or you know do you
put in there some sort of clawback
clause of if you follow these slap
lawsuits you know then you're you know
that we need to address that I don't
exactly know what the answer is but it
is it is concerning that that you can
take somebody straight to court um the
use of I believe the broadcasters did
send us Amendment language on need to
Circle that around um I don't I'm in
that same suit of like you know if I
publish a a fake deep fake AI about you
but I put it on Facebook is Facebook now
liable um you know so I think these are
other things we have to be concerned of
but to that to your to your underlying
point which you said at the very end
which is we were trying to go after the
person that's creating it um I can see
some justification for that but I think
it's the the word the appearance of the
word person and distribute that really
got me thinking about this
bill uh representative bone yeah I agree
with that yeah we should should be suing
the Creator not the distributor who may
not knowing that it's fake so really the
person that really should be responsible
is the creator
not the innocent distributor who thinks
it's real I mean so yeah I I agree with
that it's the Creator that's
responsible yeah unless distributor
knows that it's fake yeah and I'll
circle around the language from the
broadcasters um after this so everybody
can look at it because I believe they
had similar concerns um which I think
are I don't want the
broadcasters to be in the business of
policing paid political advertisements
um they're just they're just advertisers
in my mind the owner should fall on to
uh the owner I believe should fall on to
um the person that actually did it paid
for it yes representative wood thank you
Mr chairman I have a a concern similar
to uh representative qua that that it
tries to go too far I mean we'd go with
videos there's a slight difference
between a meme and something real um
spend enough time with almost anything
you can make it look real and there is
issues with just being creative and ver
versus taking advantage of of this I
believe the the um I just was reading
that the person who did the meme of
President Biden talking uh didn't
distribute it he just someone asked him
to make it he made it so I don't even
know what his intent was in this but I'm
just saying this is a very complicated
situation and when you try to put
something in here that takes care of
everything I don't know where you draw
the lines in this thing it's it's it's a
um a jungle of there hence the work
session representative
Lane um thank you uh I guess if the
broadcaster or the distributor knows
that it is a
fake knly if they know then they should
not
be Distributing it um and I don't know
whether
I mean I would hate to have them have to
go to court to prove it because again
that's a a barrier but and you'd have to
get an injunction but if they know that
it is
fake um and it's not satire and it's not
comedy um then they should not be
broadcasting it I mean to me
I you know if you know it if you know
that it's fake and there's some really
good ones out there that but if they
know or they're told by the other
candidate hey that's not me they made
that up at least question it you know
put put a pause button on it you know
because it can be very hurtful if it
just keeps going and the distributor
goes oh I didn't know and it also would
provide someone with a lot of
money the ability to Simply pay any
broadcaster any fee knowing that they
are going to be able to distribute
widely a fraudulent deceptive deep
fake and they would be able to get away
with it simply because they paid for it
yeah and there's something to this this
is not memes the robo call was not a
meme it was a fraudulent deep fake
intended to deceive
voters this is an area of
technology that it's a new it's a new
age we're not used to this yet but we
can't sit back and do nothing so even
though this is a
complicated subject and you know we may
not have all of the tools in the toolbox
to defend against um fraudulent deep
fakes if we do nothing then the courts
the AG the secretary of state the law
enforcement will have no Tools in their
toolbox to go after things that are
intentionally made to
deceive um to deceive voters to deceive
people to commit fraud this is an area
where there's a lack of Statute to deal
with this sort of thing and this is one
step forward and I fully expect down the
line as we become more aware of
artificial intelligence capability is
that there will be amendments to this
there will be further regulation there
will be regulation not at only at the
state level but at the federal level but
we have a responsibility to Granite
Staters to provide some kind of
action uh that protects them from being
deceived um and that is not only the
voters but it is also the
candidates this is
is a necessary step particularly this
year we have already seen that it costs
a couple of dollars and 20 minutes to
make a deceptive deep fake audio of the
president of the United
States telling people not to vote that's
step
one there's more coming down the line
this year in fact the technology is
advancing so much that
AI technology can be engaging in a back
and forth discussion with someone who
answers the phone and have information
about that
person to say hi this is Uncle Joe
calling you know there's been an
accident at the polling location do not
go to the polling location it is too
dangerous you know this is your Town
moderator
calling there is a threat at your
polling location the governor has issued
an extension on
voting you don't worry your vote will be
C can be cast
tomorrow this this is the kind of thing
that's coming down the line um it's not
just a one minute recorded audio on your
phone with an app it is a real threat to
democracy um and a real threat to um
everyone no matter it's not a
nonpartisan issue but that's the
advancement that's taking place here
that you could be having a conversation
on the phone with an AI bot made to
sound like somebody you
trust telling you not to vote telling
you this or that and that's where this
technolog is going and if we don't take
a step now towards some kind of
Regulation we're going to be in big
trouble okay so I I don't think I don't
think anybody's saying we don't need to
do anything um the the fact that we're
having a work session on this bill
should tell you that we're serious about
it right if I just wanted iell it I
would have send it to a 101 death and we
would have moved on um so I don't think
you have to worry about that I think we
are we're trying to get to a place that
encompasses those concerns um you know
some things that you just mentioned are
already protected by law like if you
answer the phone and it's a machine
that's a violation of tcpa um because
that's an automation so some of those
things are already covered that being
said we do need I believe we need
something in place to get what is truly
deceptive truly intention and but we're
you know kind of per our conversations
about cign finances we're walking a fine
line of you know satire right protected
Free Speech versus actual
fraud so I representative bom yeah a lot
of stuff is already in section shall not
apply to radio television broadcasting
station blah blah not including cable or
satellite television uh shall not apply
to material that constitute satire or
parody I mean that's already in the law
I think what may be needed in these
things
is the go after the Creator and also
those that
knowingly
broadcast or
or copy what the what they know is false
but just I mean but I think it sort of
covers you know that already
in un apply to radio or television and
all that so I mean I think right now
it's a lot of it there we might need
some minor but I think it's something
that probably should go forward forward
with yeah some corrections and I think I
think intent is we're trying to wrap in
intent here right if the broadcaster
knows and still does it that's intent
right that's different um versus you
know if they're handing something and
this is fraud you're trying to go after
the person committing the fraud act
right not not Aunt uh Aunt Edith who's
just forwarding an interesting video for
example going after persons who are
Distributing if if uh could I have just
your Indulgence for a moment I have a
general thought on this sure I think
that the only real solution to this
problem is that people will are going to
eventually
learn that
RE Audio Visual and image recording is
no longer trustworthy as evidence of
anything that's how far the technology
is Advanced yeah and that's and and for
that matter phone phone calls I mean my
mother would get phone
calls you know classic phone call yeah
this is your nephew uh and I'm in jail I
need send me money I mean this and and
and one one further thought I just think
this is interesting yeah this phenomenon
is not new the earliest example I'm
aware of occurred in
1940 in Paris France outside an Infamous
rail car where uh indescribably Infamous
head of State gave a little stamp of his
foot out of delight at just having
conquered
France and the British took that little
film clip and repeated it so it looked
like he was doing a little Dance
seriously this is real it's not an
internet
rumor I just think that's a it's it's an
old problem and and I just I just agree
with the general remark by
representative B that we need to focus
on going after the people who are
perpetrating you creating these frauds
and uh you know good luck with that but
I think it's worth making the effort
yeah some of them will be stupid and
catchable representative wood all right
yeah thank you Mr chairman um I I agree
this is very difficult to do this in a
simple manner we're looking at a
technology that everybody's afraid of in
this room I mean this is going to be so
unbelievable that you're going to
everybody's going to know it it's it's
false just indulge with me I'm not
trying to words you out uh the the
reality is where over here appears to be
reasonable person to depict uh that
something is different here the
reasonable I mean we we we have a
situation here that we we're going to
call out all the fire engines and we
don't have even a good definition for it
I think that's what you were mentioning
early of of how we're going to uh Corral
the troops around this thing I think
creativity is something that you can't
stop these people are going to create
these things it's OD is whatever they
have in their mind they're going to
create it if they don't do anything with
it it's not I'm sorry I I don't believe
it's against the law not a lawyer so
there's a lot of things that have to go
together here you know and just because
someone creates it doesn't mean that
they get it out in in the public so I
just don't see how any of this goes
together at this point no I think it's a
very fair point I mean creation
distribution together like if you just
make it on your computer and scks on
your computer who cares but it's when
it's distributed that it becomes an
issue um that's a very good
point uh anyone else because we're going
to call it here in a minute and come
back to this representative
Lane I'm sorry I okay maybe you make
same point
okay as to the definition of a
reasonable person um I mean it it it's a
legal concept and it and I'm not sure
that we can put it in the statute
because but it is something that's
commonly used and commonly known in
lawsuits and in the legal environs so I
I don't think we need necessarily to
Define reasonable person in the statute
yeah no I I agree it's a common
principle I mean they use it for
obscenity um you know and ultimately
that is why you have a judge that's why
they're called a Judge they judge if a
reasonable so uh representative prom O
Brien thank you I I think this is needed
legislation and uh I think that people
in the community and will in general be
more wise to this as time goes on I'm
thinking of War of the Worlds remember
that that was even prior to what you
were talking about would anybody fall
for that now and that unfortunate
example you were talking you know I hope
not um that that example that you were
talking about with the town moderator
call says there's a problem at the
polling don't go you can go later if
that's true or not I I think in I'm just
thinking of how that would go in in my
Community I think people would start
talking online calling each other
finding out if that was real and that
recent case at Dartmouth where there was
a um a doctor who was accused of saying
some racist things on some video that
went viral and it turned out he was
actually in surgery or something and
could not have ever done that and and he
explained and and people realized it
wasn't him I think people will get more
wise to this I think that's that's part
of the point here is is to make people
aware that this can happen and that you
need to have trusted sources of
information to go to to verify what
you're being shown or heard or you know
uh whatever it may be so in a situation
like that you would want to know okay
let me call my town
offices um but in passing legislation
like this we are getting the awareness
out to people so that they know that
it's out there um that legislation like
this can be a deterrent for Bad actors
um you know I certainly don't claim that
this will stop all deep fake
disinformation um but it's something and
it it can stop some and the threat of a
lawsuit May deter someone from creating
something um which is why that's in
there
um you
know I
think I think this is a step in the
right direction and I do agree with
representative Lan that a lot of the
language in here it's legal ease it's
it's language that comes from
lawyers um because they have acted on
this exact language before in court and
that's why it exists there there because
you know that's um what has been
successful in the past in front of a
judge and in in law um so while we may
not love all of the language it's there
for reason uh you know acting in good
faith and reasonable those are things
that um you can adjudicate so um we're
GNA wrap this up here but I want to end
it with this kind of statement which is
when we're talking about this bill in
particular we are talking about
specifically political speech because
the the thing with the Biden phone call
was already illegal um RSA 6594 is about
intimidation and suppression of Voters
right so having having the the thing
that you're talking about of hey it's
you're moderate or don't go vote today
that's already illegal um so we are
talking we we have to put that aside
because we've already covered that the
law already covers that um and they
should be it's it's a class B felony
it's like it's not like it's like a slap
on the wrist like it's it's j jail time
um but we're talking
about deceptive political advertising
basically
of misrepresenting a candidate's
position because if you use that
candidate or prominent political figure
to tell people not to vote that's
already a violation um it's already a
felony I should even call it a violation
it's a felony um so anyways I'm going to
leave that there I appreciate the
committee's Indulgence on the sacred
week of uh School of uh School vacation
I don't even get schoool vacation I
can't even say it school vacation uh
we're going to do this again next week
we'll do like another 45h hour on
campaign finance and then we'll come
back to uh
uh and then uh and then we'll come back
in uh 45 we will not I can assure you it
will not be 45 seconds
um nice try though yes so with that uh
we'll it that in this work session I'm
going to go eat lunch and uh go make
some money somewhere in my Chalker
Center I guess
so no we're not going to do you com all
up